bonsoir bonsoir jean louis aubert wii
qui chante du houellebecq qui met en
musique ben oui c'est très à la mode ex
de houellebecq
les douze hommes rapaillés ici où on
perd au oui exactement 1 claude péloquin
et ce phénomène existe en france aussi
alors jean louis aubert leader de
téléphone qui chante donc des textes de
michel houellebecq prix goncourt 2010
juste juste pour vous montrer à quoi ça
ressemble et leur jeunesse du projet
ensuite on est quoi
ce que
et
voilà sa soeur
à toi
les ans effectif
je
étant
la joie
à pau
victime
donc michel houellebecq dans l'allée lui
j'imagine oui les particules
élémentaires la carte et le territoire
jean-louis aubert
oui voilà j'en ai au baril tombé sur un
recueil de poèmes le dernier
configuration du dernier rivage il est
tombé fou amoureux eu l'idée de faire
une chanson et l'envoyer par courriel à
michel houellebecq chez hoebeke 10 et
même meilleures puisque je fais moi même
alors pour jean louis aubert fer s'est
élevé la chanson à un niveau incroyable
je cite donc voilà ça vous intéresse si
votre auteur préféré ou qu'elles soient
intéressants sion pour ça les qui lie
l'ue quilit-quilit c'est une chanteuse
suédoise de 28 ans qui est une rock une
découverte
ouais c'est que votre votre italienne ou
tignes et on en a beaucoup parlé aussi
on utilise retenez ça nous allait dans
la chronique sur notre site parce que
c'était très très mal revient sur les
quais les troisième album i never heard
donc je n'apprends jamais ce ne sont que
des balades en fait c'est de la musique
pour pleurs et je sais pas si vous avez
besoin d'un musée pour que leurs aînés
pour patrice j'ai complètement adoré
beaucoup beaucoup la réverbération ont
créé en voyage on est gros
faux
msa
ep
ce taux
com
p
l'ambiance oui vraiment et que des
ballades que des chansons tristes et une
espèce de mélancolie dévorante moi j'ai
vraiment adoré shorter en plus ce
troisième album i never heard
j'apprends jamais imaginé nous lui qui
lit très bel équilibre sur le découvert
absolument on se laisse avec une moins
grosse découverte on la connaît depuis
longtemps mais graal est pas bien oui
bah le 20 ans seulement nikki yanofsky
montréalaise sans son deuxième album
cette semaine de l'eau s'écoule réalisé
par quincy jones
les légendes achats groupe ça groove et
qui est lui a pas l'habitude de
travailler avec l'hyper dans tout bon
album
et
c'est bon ça c'est joyeux c'est bien
s'est reproduit cette table et réalise
voilà merci à la semaine prochaine
oui
mais